[Musica]
sono una chirurga oncologa ho dedicato
gli ultimi 15 anni della mia vita a
questo
tutto è nato da un progetto un progetto
di libertà
cresciuta in una famiglia di persone
semplici dove tutto sembrava possibile
da un orologiaio che otto anni ha
iniziato ad aggiustare orologi nella
bottega di quartiere prè vita alla sua
famiglia
ed è una sarta che pressa deciso di
lasciare quella che poteva essere la sua
ambizione per dedicarsi
con un senso di abnegazione al lavoro
travolgente
scegliere di fare la chirurga un color è
venuto naturale da una parte la passione
per le sfide impossibili dall'altra
un'accesa curiosità scientifica e in
fondo la profonda consapevolezza di
poter cambiare le sorti di qualcuno
travolto da una diagnosi feroce
ma cosa vuol dire fare la chirurga
oncologa oggi vuol dire far diagnosi
vuol dire trattare vuol dire conoscere
la malattia ancor prima di sapere come
poterla curare vuol dire seguire il
paziente lungo tutto il percorso della
sua malattia e cercare di cucirgli
addosso
un approccio quanto più dedicato a lei a
lui
vuol dire entrare nella complessità del
cancro ed uscire da quella visione
semplicistica che ha sempre visto noi
chirurghi come coloro che asportano il
superfluo come facevano gli antichi
cerusici barbieri che viaggiavano di
villaggio in villaggio a tagliare barba
e capelli medicare ferite togliere denti
se la rivoluzione degli ultimi anni è
stata la comprensione dei meccanismi
biologici che biologici che sottendono
il cancro
l'individuazione di bersagli terapeutici
la rivoluzione di questi anni la
comprensione dell'inter relazione che
c'è tra il cancro e sistema immunitario
e sicuramente l'utilizzo fine della
tecnologia una tecnologia che noi veri
vediamone i device scusiamo in sala
operatoria l'applicazione della
strumentazione robotica l'applicazione
di sistemi di machine learning
noi realizziamo big data
comprendiamo l'inter relazione che c'è
tra i dati clinici e le immagini
usiamo sistemi di machine learning per
cercare il disegnare un percorso
di diagnosi trattamento formazione e in
fondo
lavoriamo nella predizione della cura e
della sopravvivenza del paziente
ricordandoci però sempre di mettere a
fattore la qualità di vita che
dedichiamo al paziente
e per chi di noi ha successo e anche
riconoscimento delle proprie idee i
propri progetti delle proprie tecniche
su scala nazionale e internazionale
eppure quando mi fermo a pensare
che mi domando in questo che è
importante fluire delle mie giornate che
spesso assume le caratteristiche di una
corta coli
mi domando che cosa ci sia sotto
allora mi ricordo perché mi sono
iscritta alla facoltà di medicina
io mi sono iscritta a medicina per fare
la differenza per essere la miglior
opzione per i miei pazienti
e per essere la miglior opzione talora
può essere necessario individuare un
percorso
altrove anche all'estero
quando il desiderio di formazione prima
e professionalizzazione poi non sembrano
rispondere a quello che avevi in mente
il mio estero sono stati gli stati uniti
da grande scuola di opportunità e vi
dicevo in quei momenti
quando pensi ad arrivare pensi alla fama
il si ad essere riconosciuto per quello
che sai che sai fare
che ti rendi conto la tecnologia passerà
la fa ma passerà
a prendersi quella degli ammalati non
passerà mai
perché
l'ammalato affida a noi non il suo corpo
quando entra in sala operatoria ma la
sua vita i suoi sogni e su ambizioni
suoi progetti i saggi di danza dei suoi
figli
quel viaggio dovrebbe sempre voluto fare
quella casa che aveva in animo di
comperare e noi possiamo partecipare a
tutto questo possiamo renderlo possibile
la cura comincia il giorno in cui il
paziente varca la soglia del nostro
studio non finisce mai
perché fare la chirurgo oncologo dire
fare un patto con il malato io mi
prenderò cura di te ne
vuol dire anche accettare all'aperta di
qualcuno vuol dire sedersi di fronte
alle famiglie provava ricostruire
provare a parlare
sedesse accanto al malato e provare a
disegnare un altro percorso
quando quello che avevamo stabilito non
sembra regalare con le chance sicura
avevamo in mente
vuol dire vedere diritti di fronte ai
propri errori proprio fallimento che le
proprie complicanze e accettare gli
esseri umani non sovraumani in quello
che è un costante equilibrio tra
prendersi a cuore la vita di qualcuno e
non lasciarsi travolgere dal suo dolore
tra l'autocritica e la colpevolezza
tra dire la verità non togliere la
speranza in questo si giocano le nostre
vite vite che richiedono un investimento
costante in quello che siamo noi come
esseri umani come human being come madri
padri fratelli amici
runner pittori sognatori perché sono da
quell'investimento costante che possiamo
acquisire la forza di rimanere in piedi
nella tempesta
perché di tempeste ce ne sono e ce ne
saranno sempre e fallire terribile
soprattutto dal tuo fallimento ne deriva
la perdita di chance di quel paziente
che aveva varcato la soglia del tuo
studio
e fallire terribile ed è ancora più
difficile se sei una donna
perché non ci sono precedenti non c'è
letteratura molto spesso 6 la prima o
forse la più giovane
fare la chirurga difficile sempre ma lo
è di più quando c'è di mezzo all'errore
edalini importanza della squadra della
tua gente che ti guarda le spalle del
tuo team
l'importanza di avere una figura di
riferimento un mentor e
l'importanza anche di essere qui oggi in
questo momento raccontare una storia a
servire da role model in quello che è un
costante investimento in un ambiente
inclusivo l'unico ambiente che conta un
ambiente in cui ciò che è importante è
solo quello che sei e che sai fare
e in quell'ambiente tu puoi arrivare a
prendere il comando perché anche se la
società non è pronta anche se la tua
comunità cerca di proteggerti
dall'errore talvolta anche da te stessa
anche se tu talora vaccini il tuo posto
è lì su quella nave in tempesta e le
emozioni che hanno sempre rappresentato
lo stigma del genere femminile sono in
realtà alla base della tua leadership
emotiva e sono la forza che ti
permetterà di essere la miglior opzione
alla risoluzione della crisi nella
gestione del conflitto
basti così non devi essere più brava più
adeguata più performante
più uomo basti così
e allora bastiamo così diritto in piedi
nella tempesta
sostenute dalla conoscenza
strette nelle nostre emozioni con lo
sguardo rivolto alle stelle andiamo
avanti
never stop crying
[Applauso]
[Musica]